listen up if you think maths is boring
then you obviously have not heard of
Eddie woo he's arguably Australia's most
famous maths teacher making numbers easy
to understand and get this he makes it
fun he has become a big hit on YouTube
attracting out over 8 million views
around the world that's bigger than
Beyonce and last night anyone was named
as a 20-18 that local hero of the year
of the year and master mathematician
Eddie wood joins us from Canberra Eddie
so nice to meet you I've heard so much
about you why do you love maths look for
me it was a surprising discovery
actually because English and history of
my favorite subjects in school but when
I was encouraged to actually become a
mathematics teacher I thought no what I
better sort out what this subject is
about and work out what it actually is
and why it matters and I was very
surprised to discover it's a beautiful
subject it's incredibly practical and it
shows you the connections between things
you would never have guessed so there's
always Emma's surprises when you're
learning mathematics yes well you have
become such a hit on YouTube and I mean
maths can be very dry and and very tough
explain to kids and parents who haven't
seen what you do how you make it
interesting and relevant and fun
mathematics is a subject is all about
connections and number one you've got to
get a connection with the person who's
helping you learn and I feel like that's
the you know 80% of what I do is
understanding people and working out ok
well so what makes you tick what are you
interested in you love footy ok well
let's talk about parabolas because every
time you kick a ball through the air
without fail it traces out this perfect
mathematical shape why don't we explore
it so first like that connection there
is really important and secondly what I
love is that mathematics just opens your
eyes to things that you never saw before
I've been wearing glasses for 20 years
now I'm very sort of it's I'm an old
hand at this kind of thing and when I
couldn't see before I didn't realise I
couldn't see and then I put my steaks on
and I thought my goodness
oh there you are mom I didn't know
that's what you looked like but learning
mathematics is the same
you actually are opened to a whole world
that you didn't know existed and my
experience is that when students get a
taste of that they kind of hooked and
they want more Eddie you are a gym and
no one you've got 8 million views on on
your what you call whoo - it's just
fantastic congratulations on the honor
and we'll catch up Wrigley during the
year you're our sort of blood car I
think we might bring you in every time
there's a foul ball and just yeah I can
do you right out the main lesson is
don't do it but that's flying I can
explain that too if you hide which I
think congratulations Eddie